we have a question from jigger444
you mentioned you had trouble cutting
down some of the aria chapters for a
dance with dragons
would you ever post the unused material
on your website
um no probably not
um i do save everything when i when i
cut material i do save it
because i may find a place for it later
and there are things that uh
you know i cut out a second book that i
find a place where in the fourth book
and
that sort of thing is is is uh
constantly going on but
i'm still carrying forward material that
i cut from the first book uh
some of it as short as a single pithy
sentence that i particularly liked but
no longer
fit and others um
half chapters uh of that uh
that i took out um and maybe i'll find a
place for that but i have a feeling that
much of that
and more will still be in my uh my
files when uh when the whole series is
done uh
but i don't know i ever wanted getting
out there
it's it's uh it's uh you know
taken out for a reason there's one
chapter from uh
from the new book from dance with
dragons that uh i
this does go beyond game of thrones but
uh i'll be vague uh
there's this this tyrion chapter that
drove me crazy all through the the
decade that seemed that i worked on on
death with dragons and his precursor
fees for crows uh
where i kept putting it in and then
taking it out and then putting it in and
then taking it out and then i put it in
as a dream sequence and then i took it
out and
then i made it a series of recurring
dreams each one going slightly further
so i put it in seven chapters
and then i took it out of those seven
chapters and
it's it's uh
it's one of those chapters that i think
is by itself is
is a is a terrific chapter i i like the
way it came together
it's vivid it's kind of spooky it's uh
got some really great visual imagery in
it and it leads me absolutely down a
dead end where if i take that path
i'm kind of stuck on a on a detour
and so i had to take it out that chapter
i may
i don't know publish at some point down
the road but not most of the other
material